well you just saw the numbers it looks
like tonight could be bernie sanders
last stand as of tomorrow morning fully
half the delegates in the democratic
race will have been awarded
if sanders suffers a lopsided defeat in
the next few hours his path to the
nomination
will essentially disappear if that
happens millions of bernie supporters
will wake up in the morning outraged and
disappointed they'll believe sanders had
the nomination
stolen from him by a ruthless democratic
establishment fearful of change and to
some extent
they'll be right but there's another
important reason that bernie sanders
appears to be losing tonight
he's weak yes sanders is a socialist
bomb thrower who praises fidel castro
but it's mostly talk in the end
underneath it all bernie sanders may be
the lamest revolutionary
ever twice in a row sanders has tried to
win the democratic presidential
nomination
twice in a row party insiders have
worked to rig the game against him
in 2016 leaked emails showed democratic
officials openly rooting for hillary
clinton his opponent
the party scheduled the primary debates
that year in a way they thought would
hurt
sanders the dnc even entered into a
joint
fundraising agreement with his opponent
the clinton campaign remarkable
the democratic party did far more to
subvert the democratic
process four years ago than vladimir
putin even attempted to do
sanders was never going to win when he
finally did lose sanders did not even
complain about it he dutifully showed up
at the democratic convention
and endorsed hillary clinton when the
extent of her treachery became clear in
those leaked emails
sanders still campaigned for her like
the obedient little party hack he is
but hillary was not even grateful for it
she bashes sanders extensively in a new
documentary
and not just his policy she goes after
him personally claiming nobody likes him
so what did sanders learn from all of
this not
a single thing a week ago the entire
democratic party coalesced with stunning
speed around joe biden you're watching
the results tonight
it's not as if the establishment
actually prefers biden who is frail and
rapidly moving toward incapacitated
they just despise bernie sanders and
were desperate to stop him
they'd pick anybody and they did and it
worked sanders got crushed on super
tuesday
a candidate who actually wanted to win
would have paused the day after to
reassess his campaign
for sanders this week was the time to
tell the truth about what is happening
what we're all watching
the democratic nominating system is
rotten and corrupt
biden himself clearly is not capable of
governing this country he's not even
capable of holding a press conference
the whole process is shocking it's a
fraud not to mention incredibly cynical
and reckless the establishment doesn't
care who the president is
they just want to make certain it's
someone they can control who won't raise
their taxes
sanders could have said all that and he
should have because it's true
instead he defended joe biden watch and
the question of
joe biden's mental acuity is not
something that just comes up
anywhere democrats have brought this up
including senator cory booker who
endorsed joe biden
today i'm not going to go at that level
and attacking for joe and i
have you know that's for people to
decide all i can say is joe and i have
very
significant political differences and
i'm not going to be making you know
personal attacks on joe that's not what
i do
okay so according to bernie sanders
we're not allowed to talk
about the one thing all of us can see
clearly every day
the democratic front runner is failing
he's not capable of taking the job he's
running for
his staff is desperate to keep him from
interacting with the public
for more than two minutes by the way
that's not a partisan talking point
it's true it's an observation that
everyone who pays attention has
and it's sad really sad more poignant
than damning sincerely
but sanders won't say any of this shut
up he says any mention of biden's
rapidly declining communication skills
is a quote personal attack it's pretty
obvious that sanders doesn't want to win
he's a man who thinks it's more noble to
fail than to succeed
you're watching a professional loser
sanders has all been admitting that now
he's already promised to back biden
if biden wins the nomination he's even
pledged not to contest the convention
if biden falls short of a delegate
majority watch
if at the end of the day it turns out
that vice president biden is going to
have more delegates than you do
heading into the convention will you
drop out
that question will drop back you will
win i mean you will run through i
suspect we will run through
the uh process i think people have a
right to vote but if biden walks into
the convention
or at the end of the process has more
votes than me he's the winner and that's
true
with whether or not he has a majority or
just a plurality absolutely
oh absolutely it says bernie's
absolutely it's pathetic
actually real revolutionaries go to the
wall for what they believe bernie
sanders won't even go to the convention
because that's who bernie sanders is and
that's who he has
always been back in 2015 at a rally in
seattle two demonstrators
took the mic from sanders while he was
trying to speak
rather than take back his own podium
sanders stood meekly aside like a
scolded child
and then he called off the event
altogether without even finishing his
speech
imagine doing that yourself imagine how
much self-loathing you would have
would your kids even look at you in the
face probably not but he kept doing it
less than two months ago one of sanders
supporters did
what he wouldn't do she told the truth
about joe briden she called him corrupt
and she did it for a reason for decades
biden was a paid lackey of the credit
card companies
but sanders wouldn't play along he
apologized for what his surrogate said
and then he claimed joe biden was
ethically pure sanders attacked his own
surrogate
for telling the truth so what did
sanders get in return for doing that
well more attacks of course you could
have guessed it his opponents continued
to denounce him
and his supporters as sexists and
bullies and losers and they're still
doing it tonight and they'll keep it up
unto the generations because personal
attacks are what they do best
or is bernie in this secretly enjoying
it all
losing proves he's ideologically pure
he wants to you just feel sorry for his
voters some of them thought this was a
real campaign
the joke's on them